all right Anthony's with us in Michigan
Anthony welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thanks I have a large restaurant in the
process I've accumulated about a hundred
and thirty seven thousand of credit card
debt you financed the building of a
restaurant on a credit card no no no
it's just in the process of where'd the
credit card that come from go on
vacation while you're building it well
some was from before but a good amount
was and not being able to pay myself
during these first first few years
thankfully though exactly the point
earlier this year where it was actually
paying off its debts quickly and this
was starting off to go down but
including 150 that it was me but of
course the crisis hit we made some quick
changes to the business that had worked
out and though the business isn't
anywhere near where it was before it
stabilized and much better than I
thought it would but paying off the debt
the business owes me and others seems
way out of reach anytime soon so with
the business stabilized they feel good
about being able to have a household
income now about a hundred and fifty
thousand going forward and our sandwich
expenses are less than that about twenty
five hundred a month so I should be able
to get on the plan to pay it off little
bit about that but some of the interest
rates are high so the question is how do
I go about finding the most efficient
way to dig out of this hole okay Dave
let me read this one okay
well looking at this you know first and
foremost Anthony if you want a surefire
method of getting out of this debt how
many credit cards do you have for this
137 it is a total okay and you were
financing your lifestyle as you were
working the restaurant with these credit
cards right yeah so here's the reality I
want you to list these out smallest to
biggest I know you're thinking interest
rate I know you're trying to do math my
friend and you're looking at it and
you're going this one has a higher
interest rate than this one I'm gonna
tell you the debt snowball approach
listen it out smallest the biggest you
make minimum payments on everything
except for the small one
everything but the kitchen sink at it
that's how you get out of debt
it's about momentum you said we are you
married yeah so what would your
household income be if you're pulling
150 down there's only one earner oh
that's a household income sort of
committed to that so um so though that
that's nice I'm glad and I hope you can
do that that that would be a wonderful
success story on the restaurant so the
average household income in America is
fifty-nine thousand dollars okay so what
I would want you to do if you have made
a mess this big if I were in your shoes
what I would do if I had made a mess
this big is I would live on less than
that less than average like nothing at
home dude you have a huge mess you're
not a prosperous restaurant owner you
are a broker restaurant owner deeply in
debt and very scared if you're smart and
so thirty thousand dollars out of a
hundred and fifty is wimpy wimpy wimpy
wimpy you need to put out of a hundred
and fifty thousand you need to put I
don't know a hundred thousand on this
debt or seventy five thousand on this
net and be done with this whole thing in
eighteen months to two years and then
Chris is right the interest rates start
to not matter because you're not going
to be in debt very long don't keep this
crap around like like it's a pet and
dude you've been rationalizing on your
lifestyle for some time because how you
went this far in debt just to support
your family means you didn't cut
lifestyle while you're building it and
if this is only what to cover your
family's needs you wouldn't be this far
in debt you bought a bunch of family
wants while you're building the
restaurant and that's what puts you this
far in debt Michigan's not that
expensive